avec cette nouvelle convention avec
l'organisme action logement
saint-quentin-en-yvelines oeuvre pour le
rapprochement habitat emploi on lance
une
une opération avec des acteurs
spécialisés dans pour mieux accompagner
les demandes de logement pour mieux
informer donc donc le beau objectif
c'est qu'ils sont d'améliorer l'offre de
logement et pour qu'elles correspondent
encore plus aux attentes des salariés
des entreprises
bien sûr de l'agglomération de saint
quentin seuls 35% des salariés qui
travaillent sur le territoire et y
habite
le but de l'opération est d'atteindre
50% en 2020 l'agglomération souhaite
aussi les attirer grâce à ces atouts
nous leur offrons je dirais une vie en
dehors du travail une vie assez intense
que ce soit d'un point de vue culturel
sportif de loisirs c'est une
cinquantaine new line c'est quand même
une communauté d'agglomération très très
verte très diversifiée où on peut
s'épanouir sur son temps libre et donc
ça c'est déjà je dirais à
une façon d'accueillir les salariés et
de les fidéliser sur notre territoire
des jeunes actifs à la session aidée à
la propriété en passant par le logement
intermédiaire
cette convention a pour but d'aider les
salariés à chaque étape de la vie
professionnelle